il ya déjà des rumeurs sur le candidat
qui pourrait nous représenter dans les
prochaines de ce que france télé et des
gens recherchent
regardez on va le découvrir ensemble ce
que c'est une exclu des pmp regarder
après l'incroyable performance dhamir
le sublime graindelavoix de la
magnifique alma
ou encore la légendaire france gall la
nation française aura peut-être
l'honneur d'être représentée par
l'artiste le plus complet de sa
génération pour les vivants cyril
hanouna un interprète à fleur de peau
capable de tout chanter i give you may
force one you phénomène
je te laisse mes notes je te donne ma
voix
un timbre de voix qui fait frissonner un
saltimbanque polyglotte niche ich liebe
dich près de celle du ch pays d'angela
merkel cyril hanouna objectif eurovision
2020 ces messieurs ont cautionné magie
n'habitions bon ta gueule
[Musique]
je vais vraiment passé et se disent les
auditions écrira titre à huy ouais mais
aussi avec vous sans vous dire déjà
l'allemagne le titre du titre le titre
voilà ça va être moitié anglais moitié
français ouais moi je savais que cela ça
ne m'est rien arrivé parce qu'ils n'ont
pas franchement je vous le dit ballack
c'est encore un exemple savoir le titre
merci à les installer voit sa démission
n'est pas terminée ce qui les inquiète
justement alors quelle mission n'est pas
terminée donc on se calme on se rassoit
isabelle main merci
maxime on se rassoit gars bien sûr je
vais donner le titre voilà bah non je
vais te dire tu sais comment le jeu vous
dire le titre assez vous on est assis
ici un rôle ou quoi on a essayé vous moi
si je vais le donner aux téléspectateurs
ce chalet on a déjà commencé à écrire
avec les auteurs ce sera un titre en
anglais mais arrêter mais bon dodo à
rien couche
un dos nu mais sans rien mais vous êtes
fous asseyez-vous milan ac et voudront
jeunesse parfois châssis l'étranger à 6
le team va s'appeler aftereight pourquoi
parce que sa fan de chocolat
[Applaudissements]
tous les cheminots ne vous inquiétez pas
havaianas joliot la régie c'est la régie
qui a envoyé tout seul
ouais ouais bien sûr la résine